in a completely cowardly pathetic
disgusting but yeah absolutely
predictable move
house republican leaders are coming out
in opposition to even
investigating what happened on january
6th
with the trump riots in washington d.c
democrats and normal people
want to investigate january 6th because
it was an absolute
disgrace it was an outrageous tragic
moment in american history
and there are almost endless avenues of
investigation that should be pursued
who all participated who was responsible
who instigated what are the full
explanations for
delays in getting national guard and
more police to the capital
who knew what and when the day of i
could go on and on but there are endless
avenues
of questions which i would love to see
answered and yet
republicans sent out a letter republican
leaders
sent out a letter to republican members
of congress yesterday trying to convince
them to vote against a bipartisan
proposal
to launch an investigation which in
structure could be similar to the 911
commission
house minority leader kevin mccarthy a
disgusting person
came out against the bipartisan deal
saying the scope of the investigation is
too narrow now
this is really i don't is this it's not
shrewd because shrewd almost has like a
positive connotation
maybe cynical you might think wow
kevin mccarthy thinks the investigation
is too narrow so clearly mccarthy wants
to investigate
more things about january 6. that sounds
good right
wrong republicans say in their letter
that to really investigate what happened
on january 6th
you need to investigate things that are
completely unrelated
like when steve scalise got shot at
baseball practice in 2017.
the letter that they wrote says quote
this commission cannot investigate the
political violence leading up to and
following the attack on the 6th
including the june 2017 shooting at the
republican congressional baseball
practice
and the deadly attack on capitol police
on april 2 2021.
the report is due too late to properly
educate and advise
on securing the capital complex and
there is no def
prohibition against indefinite
extensions
not said there is that the january 6
rioters
were all trump supporters inspired by
trump
and maybe to some degree by right-wing
media the shooting of steve scalise in
2017 really has nothing to do with this
now on the senate side mitch mcconnell
who is the senate
minority leader says that republicans
are undecided on whether to go ahead
with the commission but they're open to
hearing arguments
some republicans have already expressed
support for the commission for example
texas republican senator john cornyn
said quote
i think we need to do something to
identify the problems
i mean shame on us if we can't address
it now i asked on twitter yesterday
why would anyone be opposed to even
investigating
the january 6th riots and i received
some really interesting responses here's
a representative sample
one viewer telling me because they are
scared the truth will be told
about things they don't want anyone to
know about another
follower of mine on twitter says they i
think they mean they
are connected to those who are
responsible
and therefore are complicit and a very
comprehensive answer
giving four reasons why republicans are
opposed to the investigation
a it will incriminate their dear leader
donald trump
b it will incriminate their voters and
supporters
c it will incriminate their fellow
republican congress members
and d it will incriminate themselves
let's hope that this panel is formed and
that the investigation
happens now one last thing in the
defense of
some republicans some republicans do
want to do this and i think that's a
good thing right
like that's something and of course this
should be done
a little bit later in the show i'll tell
you about
uh man of the people and government
transparency advocate
tucker carlson who is completely against
this investigation
really transparent right guys this is
why populism
and faux populism can be such a
pernicious thing that's a little bit
later
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company
best known for their delicious mushroom
coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer-reviewed studies i've been
drinking four
sigmatic coffee a lot lately it actually
doesn't taste anything like mushrooms it
just tastes like
any delicious coffee but it's really
easy on my stomach doesn't give me any
jittery feeling or a midday crash and
they have over
twenty thousand five star reviews
and best of all if you don't love it
you'll get one hundred percent
of your money back because they stand
behind their product
you've got nothing to lose by giving it
a try four sigmatic is giving my
audience up to forty percent
off and free shipping when you go to
four sigmatic dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath this video